ahora vamos a hablar acerca de las dos
formas que puede tomar la ecuación de
los inductores y también vamos a ver
unos ejemplos para ver la ecuación en
acción pero bueno empecemos la ecuación
de los inductores lo que nos dice es que
el voltaje a través de un inductor el
voltaje es directamente proporcional a
la velocidad de cambio de la corriente
con respecto al tiempo que hay aquí
tenemos que multiplicar por l la
inductancia pero detengámonos un momento
para recordar qué significan estas
letras aunque hay pero vamos a empezar
con un resistor a los resistor es los
denotamos con letras r
y las unidades de la resistencia son los
oms y les llamamos así a estas unidades
por el físico llamado om que las
descubrió luego también tenemos unos
capacitores que dibujamos así y a la
capacitancia de cada capacitor le
llamamos con una letra c y sus unidades
son los parados o también conocidos como
far adiós por el físico michael faraday
pero ahora para los inductores
utilizamos estas dos letras l y h l de
henrik
y h de henrik porque fue henry lens
quien hizo mucha investigación acerca de
los inductores por eso a las unidades
les llamamos henri aunque muchas veces
también lo vas a encontrar como en río r
c y l son las letras con las que nos
referimos a los componentes y homs para
ti y henry son las unidades
pero bueno regresemos aquí a nuestro
inductor la ecuación de los inductores
también se puede escribir de otra forma
donde tenemos a la corriente
directamente en términos del voltaje
pero para hacer esto tenemos que
deshacernos de esta derivada por lo que
vamos a integrar estas dos expresiones
aquí vamos a querer integrar con
respecto al tiempo entonces tenemos la
integral del voltaje con respecto al
tiempo tiene que ser igual a la integral
de l
l y luego la derivada de la corriente
con respecto al tiempo y estamos
integrando con respecto al tiempo pero
luego como esta es una constante puede
salir de la integral y luego esta
integral no es matemáticamente correcto
decir esto pero estos dos se cancelan y
nos queda el por la integral de uno con
respecto a la corriente y entonces de
esta integral nos queda y que tiene que
ser igual a uno entre el uno entre l por
la integral del voltaje con respecto al
tiempo pero ahora si nosotros
quisiéramos saber cuánto vale la
corriente en cierto tiempo t aquí
tenemos que ponerle límites a la
integral y estos límites son desde menos
infinito hasta el tiempo t ahora lo que
esto nos dice es que la corriente a
través de un inductor depende del
que transcurrió a través de ese inductor
a lo largo de toda la vida de ese
inductor pero eso no es algo conveniente
nosotros no queremos tener que saber
cuál es el voltaje a través de un
inductor a lo largo de toda su vida pero
si hay una forma de darle la vuelta por
ejemplo si nosotros sabemos cuál es la
corriente en cierto tiempo t igual a
cero digamos que sabemos cuál es la
corriente a través del inductor en el
tiempo cero entonces aquí ya tenemos la
información de un muy buen pedazo de
esta integral por lo que nos va a quedar
que la corriente la corriente en el
tiempo t mayúscula es igual a 1 / l por
la integral desde el tiempo igual a cero
hasta el tiempo t mayúscula
el voltaje en el tiempo t con respecto
al tiempo más
y de cero ok porque aquí y de cero es
igual al resto de la integral desde
menos infinito hasta cero que no estamos
poniendo por acá esta y de cero
representa todo lo que ha pasado toda la
información hasta el tiempo cero pero
bueno aquí voy a hacer un último cambio
nos gustaría que ésta tema yus q la en
realidad fuera una t minúscula por lo
que aquí vamos a poner un atajo y nos
queda que la corriente al tiempo t es
igual a 1 entre l por la integral desde
cero hasta el tiempo te del voltaje al
tiempo tau con respecto al tiempo
tau más la corriente en el tiempo cero
que ya conocemos y listo esta es la
forma integral de la ecuación de los
inductores y por acá tenemos su forma
con derivadas ahora estas dos formas se
utilizan muchísimo las dos pero en este
vídeo vamos a hacer un ejercicio en el
que utilizamos ésta
de la ecuación así es que tenemos por
aquí nuestro circuito con una fuente de
voltaje por acá tenemos el patrón del
voltaje a lo largo del tiempo podríamos
decir que esta es una gráfica del
voltaje a lo largo del tiempo y en este
circuito tenemos una corriente y nos
gustaría saber cuál es esa corriente sin
olvidarnos de que en este circuito
tenemos un inductor de 10.000 y en risk
ahora aquí analizando el voltaje a lo
largo del tiempo empezamos en cero volts
pero subimos a dos volts y después de
dos milisegundos el voltaje cae a menos
dos volts se queda así durante dos
milisegundos y después vuelve a subir a
dos volts y se queda así otros dos
milisegundos y así se sigue así es que
tenemos por aquí a de dt pero ahora lo
que queremos encontrar es y dt queremos
encontrar la corriente a través de este
inductor a lo largo del tiempo y para
encontrarla vamos a utilizar
integral de la ecuación de los
inductores ahora para hacer todo eso
vamos a necesitar espacio entonces nos
hacemos un poco de espacio por acá
tenemos que empezar de algún punto y
aquí vamos a suponer que al principio
tanto la corriente como el voltaje son
iguales a cero y también la derivada de
la corriente con respecto al tiempo es
igual a cero pero bueno esto es lo que
vamos a suponer que sucede al principio
y por acá vamos a hacer una gráfica de
qué es lo que está sucediendo lo que
descubrimos qué sucede una gráfica de la
corriente con respecto al tiempo que
vamos a graficar la corriente así es que
lo que estamos suponiendo aquí acerca de
cómo empieza este circuito es que la
corriente es igual a cero pero ahora
llegamos al tiempo cero y en el tiempo
cero el voltaje aumenta a dos volts
entonces vamos a utilizar la forma
integral de la ecuación de los
inductores
para ver como el cambio de voltaje
afecta a la corriente a lo largo del
tiempo entonces tenemos que y la
corriente al tiempo t es igual a 1 / l
por la integral desde cero hasta el
tiempo de este tiempo de el voltaje al
tiempo tau con respecto a tau ahora aquí
vamos a empezar tomando el tiempo t en
este intervalo entre 0 y 2 milisegundos
y durante ese intervalo de tiempo para
todos estos voltajes en el tiempo entre
0 y 2 milisegundos el voltaje es igual a
2 volts
así es que aquí simplemente vamos a
poner 2 positivo por cierto y luego nos
falta sumar la corriente en el tiempo
cero pero estamos suponiendo que la
corriente en el tiempo cero es cero
entonces la corriente al tiempo t
donde estamos no lo he escrito pero
estamos suponiendo que este té está en
algún lugar entre 0 y 2 milisegundos la
corriente en este tiempo es igual a 1 /
l
pero la l son 10.000 y henry
milk y henry por esta integral pero aquí
el 2 como es una constante puede salir
de la integral
así es que aquí multiplicamos por 2 y ya
nada más nos falta la integral desde
cero hasta t de 1 con respecto a tau
pero esto es igual a 2 entre 10.000 y
henri por de menos 0 lo cual es
simplemente una p cierto la corriente en
el tiempo te es igual a una constante
por t la gráfica de esto de y con
respecto al tiempo que es simplemente
una línea recta en la que 2 entre 10.000
y henri es la pendiente pero bueno aquí
la verdad me apresuré mucho dibujando
esta recta aquí porque para dibujar una
recta como ésta
necesitamos dos puntos uno de esos
puntos es cierto ya lo tenemos aquí la
corriente al tiempo cero
pero también necesitamos calcular el
segundo punto y el segundo punto es
cuando el tiempo es igual a 2
milisegundos no creí entonces ponemos
por aquí 2000 segundos y ahora sí vamos
a calcular la corriente al tiempo dos
milisegundos la corriente al tiempo 2
mili segundos es igual a 2 entre 10.000
y henry 2 entre 10.000 y hendrix por el
tiempo o sea por 2000 segundos pero esto
es igual a 4 entre 10 o sea a 0.4 milis
con 1000 y se cancelan y segundos entre
henry son amperes así es que cuando el
tiempo es igual a 2 milisegundos la
corriente mide
0.4 amperes ok entonces aquí tenemos el
final de la recta y la gráfica de la
corriente en este tiempo es esta recta
bueno ahora si ya conocemos a la
corriente a lo largo de todo este
periodo de tiempo pero nos falta seguir
adelante ahora estamos en este tiempo
ente igual a dos milisegundos y para
calcular la corriente a lo largo de este
tiempo vamos a volver a utilizar esta
forma de la ecuación de los inductores
mujer pero vamos a necesitar este
espacio ahora en el tiempo igual a dos
milisegundos la corriente es igual a 0.4
amperes 0.4 amperes y el voltaje como
podemos ver en esta gráfica es menos 2
volts menos 2 volts pero bueno en estas
condiciones tenemos que la corriente en
el tiempo te donde vamos a hacer que
este récord
desde 2000 segundos hasta 4 milisegundos
ok entonces y de t es igual a 1 entre el
que ya sabemos que son 10.000 y enric
por la integral desde 2 milisegundos
2000 segundos hasta el tiempo te que es
algún tiempo en este intervalo de el
voltaje con respecto a tau pero el
voltaje en estos tiempos en este
intervalo es igual a menos 2 entonces
podemos colocar por aquí menos 2 pero
aquí todavía nos falta sumar la
corriente inicial que ya conocemos al
tiempo 2 ms que en este caso es 0.4
amperes 0.4 amperes entonces pues aquí
tenemos que la corriente al tiempo t es
igual a 1 entre 10.000 y henry
es 1000 y henry es el menos 2 sale de la
integral tenemos aquí por menos 2 por la
integral desde 2 milisegundos hasta el
tiempo te con respecto a tau más la
corriente inicial de 0.4 amperes pero
aquí está integral este menos 2
milisegundos así es que tenemos que
volver escribirlo todo la corriente el
tiempo te es igual a menos 2 entre
10.000 y hendrix gray eso es esta parte
pero aquí está integral este menos 2000
segundos y ya nada más nos falta sumar
la corriente inicial que son punto 4
amperes pero bueno aquí tal vez no se
vea tan claro pero esta es la ecuación
de una pendiente y aquí la corriente al
tiempo t es igual a menos 2 por el
tiempo te entre los
es 1000 y henry y luego menos 2 x menos
2 es más 4 milisegundos entre 10.000 y
henry + 0.4 amperes y aquí lo que
tenemos otra vez es la ecuación de una
recta pero esta recta que por cierto
tiene que empezar por aquí esta recta
tiene una pendiente muy parecida a la
pendiente de esta recta 2 entre 10.000 y
henry pero ahora es una pendiente
negativa entonces por aquí podemos
colocar nuestra marca de los 4000
segundos y la recta es ésta porque aquí
la magnitud de la pendiente es
exactamente la misma durante el mismo
tiempo solo que negativa así es que esta
es la gráfica de la corriente a lo largo
de este pedazo de tiempo y este es un
muy buen ejemplo donde podemos ver la
ecuación de los inductores en acción